I do not think that sounds very kind of
shallow in terms of the way you look at
things like I I think it depends on what
what you need as a person because your
circumstances your upbringing your life
is gonna determine what you need from
someone else you're right there's
individual differences but when you
survey women and ask them like from the
horse's mouth at large what they want in
a guy it's money muscles frame Game what
do you mean by frame sorry frame is like
masculinity basically muscles and I will
say when you said it's also what you
need personally from a woman I was going
to point on to that I've you know we've
all been there where like you meet
someone at a time where they need a
certain kind of guy maybe she's been
dumped by some you know some players she
needs a nice guy for a bit but after
those needs have been met it's money
frames and games baby I wasn't gonna no
to that point I was gonna say why is it
about what you need like I don't think a
man goes into relationship saying what
can what do I need from a woman it's
like no like what can I provide for her
what can our family do together what
welcome like I'm I promise you I'm not
like what if a man says he wants
something from you you'd think he's a
weirdo you'd be like right he's like
well it's it's like why does he want
something from me like no you tell your
virgin if you're if you say for example
you got a friend where the guys she's
constantly paying for or she's
constantly doing
um the things that you would typically
consider a man doing yeah you would tell
her you'd be like later why are you with
that guy like he's trying to take
advantage of you yeah you see there we
go so I've heard I've heard that I've
heard that being said right so that's
what I'm talking about when I say in
terms of what you need from me I think
with I don't know if it's with age but
money
genuinely doesn't come into it for me
don't get me wrong don't get me wrong
I'm not gonna lie I will I will sit here
if I met two guys in a if I met two guys
exact same guy and one said yeah exact
same guy and one said
do you want to go out on Monday I'm
gonna pick you up and the other one said
do you want to go out Monday yeah we'll
check train times and I'll meet you
there yeah I'm not gonna lie I probably
will go for the one that's going to pick
me up right yeah what if I told you the
train guy has 35 million in his bank
account and the reason why wait wait
wait and the reason why he's not taking
car and pick dropping news because it's
in the garage would you still go with
the guy that's picking you up in the car
yeah no I don't know that I'm confused
now you're confused me stop it you can
you give yourself everyone you don't
know what you want you say what a man
just needs to be able to look after
himself yeah I just feel like you've
kind of got your stuff yeah but the
point is if there's a guy a and Guy B
and one has money and one what doesn't
yeah you're telling me you wouldn't pick
the guy with money it's exactly exactly
exactly yeah yeah you probably would
yeah yeah I mean
and they're exactly the same but just
one has money of course
because then you're not going to put
your your stuff but the point is that
plays into it where men don't care
exactly men don't care all about a
woman's money like and a lot of times
girls will come out and they'll say oh I
have my own bag and like think that's
attractive to a guy but it's only
attractive to broke men yeah of course
I am straight if you have the exact same
comparison though and you say to a guy
okay has women a and women B who are
exactly the same and the only thing how
would you pick between the two then yeah
what would it be but for us you're
assuming it
can you answer this question okay so
just rephrase the question so girl a
girl B one has money one doesn't one
makes 500k a year one makes 45. but
they're exactly that's exactly yeah
money won't I won't care about money and
the reason why I wouldn't care about
money is purely because I'm gonna judge
them like let's say go a they're exactly
the same but girl is like hella
disrespectful she doesn't understand
what I as a man need and then girl be
exactly the same understands what a man
needs is submissive in certain ways that
shows me respect and loyalty which is
what I value
I'm picking girl B
sure
so so then being exactly the same it
does money doesn't matter
I'd probably flip a coin flip a coin you
said as a minute ago you said they don't
understand what I need now when I said
looking at what you'd look at what you
need from a man you picked up on that
and said why does it matter what the
woman needs and assumed it was a
monetary value thing where I was talking
about emotionally and mentally but when
you've said that nobody said anything
that's not what I'm talking about he's
talking about in terms of the man's
needs in terms of a man's needs I could
fulfill my own needs when you're coming
into relationship you're probably coming
with University debt you're probably
coming with problems from your
ex-relationship you're probably coming
with like past issues emotional needs a
lot of everyone
so here's the difference emotional needs
you seek a man to help you with that
whereas I as a man if I've got emotional
needs I will not come to you with those
emotional needs and the reason being is
that you as a woman will not understand
the struggle that as a man that I go
through on a daily basis so it's very
difficult for you to comprehend and give
me advice on how to deal with my
emotional problems I as a man will
probably be best off
going to seek advice from other males
that I could call friends maybe
counselors in that kind of realm in
order to get advice on how to go about
my emotional problems yeah
is it best women are chemically
different on a day-to-day basis and so
the idea that I could say all right guys
I'm going through these problems you may
see it from a woman's perspective and
you'll go oh well you can do this this
and this as a man if I take that advice
I do those things I will find the
results are not suitable or what I'm
looking for because you as a woman women
tend to be multi-colored in today's
society men if you do something you will
know about it you Society will tell you
that this can't run and you can't do
that okay let me get away with
everything
yeah anytime anytime a guy has a
standard they're ashamed for it but
never started off this conversation by
saying don't you think women have two
high standards they do but I just said
50 that's why 50 of women are single and
childless that contradicts exactly what
how does it contradict exactly what I
said because you just said if men have a
standard they're kind of shamed for it
yeah I'll give you an example what what
happened with the [ __ ] shaming [ __ ]
shaming fat phobic where's the
equivalent of that for men they don't
exist
if anything if I meet anyone and they
ever say anything to me and I need a
statistic and it's about women and men
I'm foreign
[Laughter]
you're allowed to have standards as a
woman what we're talking about is too
high of a standard where it only
encompasses 20 of men that's standard if
you broaden your standard to include
like let's say 50 you'd have a higher
chance of being in a relationship
correct because you have more people so
that's what we're talking about the
reason why a lot of you are single is
because your standards are too high
men's standards are not the same like
the same the same with the two girls
with the money it doesn't matter for me
what she has the more likely I'll take
the one with less because the one with
more is going to come with complications
she's going to be like I'm the boss of
this stuff I have the most money then no
you can't tell me
I'm like yo I don't need to stress I
find it really interesting that you say
that because speaking to all of the
women that I know who are currently
single the issues that we always have
are you go on dates you put yourself
into somebody you invest your time and
they all seem to have commitment issues
so that's why because
I promise you the bottom 80 of guys they
where are they they have no commitment
issues none
they're less attractive the man has
commitment issues yeah in my experience
but that's what I'm saying to you
because he's not going to tell you
listen darling this is your problem this
is a b problem this is C problem this is
the problem I'm just gonna cut cut or
I'm gonna stay there and not take you
seriously if if he's not committing to
you is because of something you're not
doing or you're not fulfilling for him
in terms of what you want you'll need a
woman's fault if a man's not committed
if a girl is asking for let's say she
her asking prices this much and she says
this is this is the product this is what
I'm selling can someone buy it and
nobody buys something's wrong with the
product
good to know all the prices the price or
the price yeah or the price or the buyer
you're basically saying there's there's
no issue with so with the fact that it's
so easily accessible to move on to the
next person with having social media
with having dating apps now that that
hasn't caused an issue in terms of
individuals now committing